DC Entertainment has just crossed
200,000 subscribers on the YouTube
channel and to celebrate we're throwing
a massive party for ourselves so we will
see you later
we are throwing a big party but also for
the fans we are gonna give you guys an
exclusive look at the all-star Batman 75
panel from WonderCon as a massive thank
you to you thank you for subscribing
first up we have a gentleman who is
arguably an icon like Batman in his own
right
he was the illustrator of some of the
most memorable Batman stories we have
published including all-star Batman and
Robin and the now legendary Batman his
distinctive art style has influenced an
entire generation comic book artists and
fans he's now the co publisher of DC
Comics mr. Jim Lee our next guest is the
senior vice president of creative
affairs for Warner Brothers animation
among the more recent DC entertainment
projects he has overseen our Young
Justice Green Lantern animated series
the wildly inventive DC Nation shorts
beware the batman and Teen Titans go
please welcome mr. Peter Girardi our
next guest is a gentleman who is
responsible for what I believe to be one
of the most popular and influential
iterations of Batman during these last
75 years beginning in 1992 his
interpretation of the Dark Knight
spanned two decades of Warner Brothers
animated TV shows and movies his amazing
credits include Batman the animated
series Batman Beyond Justice League
Unlimited mr. Bruce Timm
our next panelist has worked side by
side with mr. Tim during this amazing
run and he is quite simply for all
intents and purposes the voice of Batman
please welcome mr. Kevin Conroy I am
vengeance I am the knight I am Batman
our next guest once wore a Batman styled
cape and cowl in a movie he is also a
director screenwriter actor author host
of the monthly podcast fat man on Batman
and a comic book writer please welcome
mr. Kevin Smith and our final guest is
well known to most of you who reside in
the Greater Los Angeles area from his
voice work on KROQ is Kevin in the bean
morning show he also hosts the Hollywood
babble-on podcast with mr. Smith and
will be co-writing the Batman Green
Hornet book coming later this year with
Kevin please welcome mr. Ralph Garman so
today what we're gonna try to do in the
brief time that's been allotted to us we
have 75 years of Batman history to cover
in about 40 minutes so hang on to your
seats we're gonna start off where we
were 75 years ago that is the covered in
Detective Comics 27 that's big auction
was in 2010 it sold for a million the
$75,000 so frankly if you brought one of
those with you today you can come up
here and do whatever you want to if you
give it to me
and the next slide I want to show you
shows a few more of those covers and you
can see that not only is Batman
celebrating his anniversary you'll see
the world of Batman is something we all
know more intimately than we would
probably admit from his sidekicks like
Robin and Batgirl and especially on the
next slide his villains which I think in
some ways are is indelible as anything
that's happened so let's go to our first
general question because it's the
easiest way to start a discussion like
this
who is your favorite Batman villain
panelists and why and I'm going to start
with Jim Lee yes I'm gonna have to go
with Catwoman because yes yes she's a
criminal
and in some ways Batman he's a vigilante
too so they both kind of share some
common ground but the same time he's a
character that you know obviously he's
got to stop and camp for whatever reason
and as she knows it too I love the fact
that she kind of plays with him just
like he's a bobble or something like
that and they look good together too so
what do you say Peter well I think maybe
two answers one is I grew up on the Adam
West and Burt Ward show so I really like
like the lot of those crazy characters
for let show but then in the more cannon
a two-face for sure I think we get all
kind of relate in the same way you like
a Catwoman any we could all kind of
relate to to face them yeah I don't
think I could actually narrow it down to
just one because I love them all for all
the various reasons but if I had to I
would say Catwoman Catwoman because
Julie Newmar there are so many I guess I
haven't an I have an unusual
relationship with Mark Hamill though so
I would have to say the Joker
and he brings out the best in me and I
bring out the worst in him so we work
well together I'm so pissed because
Batman stole my answer I'm gonna go a
bit more esoteric with the answer though
of course there's a wonderful rogues
gallery we can all choose from but in
terms of favorite villain I'm going to
I'm going to skew it a bit differently
and say favorite obstacle that Batman
has to overcome which could be a villain
it's his humanity that's the only thing
that stops him and you see the
frustration as he's portrayed throughout
every medium it's only when he hits the
ceiling of his humanity that he can
possibly be stopped and as we've seen
even then sometimes he overcomes it so
I'm going with Batman's humanity well
crap anything I say now it's going to
sound lame like Bruce because of the
series The Riddler for me always had a
special place in my heart because Frank
gorshins performance in that role was
just indelible just he created that
character for me I always think of him
that way well if it's one of my
operating theses that every generation
of America dates itself by where it
comes to Batman I think the age of our
panel was just outed by the number of
references to the next slide which is
Batman 66 the TV series that debuted
then first for those that aren't aware
if you somehow missed the announcement
that came from Conan O'Brien earlier
this year sometime late this year this
is going to appear on DVD and blu-ray
for the first time ever
finally we have been adapting Batman 66
for a little while now in digital series
we just collected it into its first
hardcover and we just found out on
Wednesday that on April 27th this book
is going to debut on the New York Times
list at number two in the hardcover
graphic novel slot which I think speaks
to the popularity of this iteration of
Batman but also the great job that our
editorial team and our talent team doing
Batman 66 has come together coming later
this year is Batman 66 means it's the
Green Hornet which Kevin and Ralph are
riding
and gentlemen there's no pressure on you
now that you know the previous users of
Batman 66 comics have become New York
Times bestsellers no one's expecting
that from you but I'm guessing based on
some of the answers I just heard and
what I know that that TV show was a real
cultural moment for you guys especially
so how much of that do you want to bring
and how much do you want to try to give
it your own spin when you do this or do
you want to say anything at all about
what you're about to do
well when Kevin I started working on the
book we realized that there had been a
strong template sort of given to us I
mean there are certain characteristics
of the show certain aspects of the show
that you have to sort of adhere to in
order to make it feel like an episode of
that show so we had this great work that
Lorenzo simple and other writers had
given via the series and then as fans
you get to play what if what would I
have liked to have seen had there been
other episodes especially when it comes
to the amazing crossover episode between
Batman and the Green Hornet and Kato and
Robin because Kevin I were talking about
I was the first superhero crossover
live-action we had ever seen what a big
impact that made on us when you think
about it like that was our Avengers when
we were kids like olesia two dudes and
Mass standing next to each other for me
I think it was just kind of important to
honor the Batman that brought us into
the world of Batman I was into Batman of
course right around 89 when the movie
came out prior to that Frank Miller took
him dark and stuff Batman kind of
returned to his more dark detect Dark
Knight Detective roots and there was
this general sentiment that if you grew
up with with the Batman Adam West's
Batman you kind of turned your back on
it man away like Peter denied Christ
like you just suddenly got to this place
with the book where people like hey man
you like that Batman too old Batman you
like no man I never watched that Batman
no man not Batman stupid you know
and somewhere [ __ ] crows um so there was
that period I think the first person the
first person who set me straight man was
Matt Wagner the great Matt Wagner did
mage and he also did for Batman a couple
Batman Grendel's and a couple other
books and he had a line at one point
where Batman was going to refer to Robin
as well little Chum and DC editorial at
that point was like don't do that don't
don't cuz people remember that show
don't do it and so they they made him
take it out and I was a good thing man
because who cares about that old Batman
that's your Grandpa's Batman and Matt
Wagner was the first one who like stood
up for that Batman he goes you know what
man don't sell out on that Batman that
was your first Batman so honored that
Batman and I was like oh Matt Wagner
schooled me and then from that point
forward I would go out to other people
and they would bag on Batman be like
your man you know what you're a poser
you should honor that Batman but it is
such a cool conceit and I think
especially the first couple promo images
the likenesses really give the covers by
Alex Ross they're just astounding
they're gorgeous even if you didn't like
Batman 66 you look at these covers and
you're like I would like to own that
cover he just he you could tell like you
know Alex is always consistently amazing
but you could tell the stuff that
captures his imagination and you can
tell that he loved Batman 66 because
those covers are mind-bendingly good so
we have one generation that's sort of
captured in that late 60s moment and
then we get to the late 80s and a couple
of big explosions happened in 1986 Frank
Miller hits with the Dark Knight Returns
probably up to that point the most
shocking iteration of Batman that was
ever there and I think anyone who was a
Batman fan or certainly a comic book
reader was stop smacked in the face when
that came out and I'm guessing that
since you've been able to work with
Frank on Batman after that Jim that's
one of those moments when you first saw
that book you didn't imagine that's
where your life was going to go yeah I
was actually a senior in college when
this book came out and all I remember
with those horrible Batman 66 cartoon
shows or TV shows going off
with this this is awful like how am I
going to think about a career in comics
if that's what I have to live up to and
I was collecting comics I still had
comics mail to my home but I was really
just unenthusiastically collecting them
and then this came out it wasn't just
that it was hand-colored wasn't just the
fact that it was on shiny paper and a
new format the level of sophistication
to the storytelling the narrative the
political themes the social themes just
blew me away and then there's a scene
where Batman he's like 70 75 years old
and he's naked he's taking a shower and
it may be tingle in a weird way in that
no no it you remember the scene right he
real he had a moustache and he realizes
he shaved it off like oh snap
like it was the force of Batman he
thought he could drop the cow but it was
deep inside him and it was just very
powerful mythical and it really got me
inspired that scene in particular to get
into comics and so I put my first
portfolio together in 87 got work
shortly after so it was a life changer I
think the other thing that's important
to remember is we love that phrase Dark
Knight now but this is when Batman went
dark I don't think in pop-culture he was
really seen that much as a dark hair I
mean coming off the TV series that
wasn't a possibility at all but but this
is where he first started getting cast
that way and that phrase had you know
today it's something that's used so
handily but it had a lot of resonance
then because the dark part of that meant
a lot and I think that was what was
fully at play in 1989 when we go to our
next slide the next big cultural quake
it
before I came in here today is telling
somebody I was doing this panel and
without any prompting they ran through
the story I remember the first time I
saw about a Michael Keaton Batman movie
and they went through a ten-minute
exegesis about remembering specifically
what night they saw how many people were
in the theater and it just again it was
a great you know reiteration to me that
everybody has those cultural moments so
I'm just curious if anybody on the panel
can remember specifically when they saw
that movie or what impact it had on them
because I think also today we've seen so
many different interpretations of Batman
going on that it's tough to remember
stuff to remember how impactful that was
yes Kevin I remember exactly where I was
I was working at Domino's it was my
first day of employment at Domino's
Pizza and I remember I was working for
two hours and they had four other
trainees there so about two hours into
the ship they realized they were over
staffed for the evening and this was
June 23 1989 it's Friday night
so my friends were all going to see
Batman at the Middletown movie theater
and the big theater theater number one
they were like we're going man you're
gonna go and lead it this is a day
before the internet no smartphones so I
couldn't like call my friend or anything
like that unless I used a payphone which
I did and I called him at his mother's
house and I was like you guys going and
he's just like yeah we're gonna go I was
like I'll buy me a ticket easy on your
working I was like I'm gonna quit so two
hours into the shift
you know the managers just like we have
too many people working on tonight so
who volunteers to go home and I was like
I do and he was like you can't your
training and I was like yeah but I feel
like you're right it's far too many
people here and I'm happy to come train
tomorrow you could put me on the same
time I wanted to count this or anything
like that I just want to get a jump
start on a real practice day like so
tomorrow will be my first real day and
he was just like okay fair enough
come back tomorrow same time
so I left and I go I got to the payphone
just one block from from a Domino's cuz
then want to see me do this and I called
up my friend Brian at his parents house
and I was just like I'm coming I'm
coming I'll meet you at the theater and
I met him at the theater they had
already bought my ticket
we went and sat dead-center man perfect
perfect seats I went with my friend
Walter Flanagan Brian Johnson Walter
flying and two guys that are on on comic
book men Jason Mewes was with us as well
and so Walter was the guy that had
handed me the Dark Knight Returns got me
back into comics so watching that movie
next to Walter I swear to you at one
point when Batman first descends in the
background the two thugs are on the
rooftop and they're having a discussion
went on you see in the background deep
background
Batman descends this is what happens
with me and Walter Flanagan we'll look
at the screen we don't even make odd
talk about contact we just Thelma and
Louise and we go I remember that one
because my then wife was very pregnant
with our soon-to-be son and if we go to
the next slide this was his bat this was
my now twenty-something year old son and
Bruce and Kevin your guys run here was
so long and so strong and at what point
if at all did you realize how big this
was going to be and how impactful this
was going to be well you know it's
really weird because it was a different
world back then there was so fewer
entertainment options because it was
before the internet before you know
video games really took off and stuff so
it sounds really kind of oddly conceited
but I kind of knew the show was going to
be a big hit more because of how big
Batman was in the public consciousness
coming off of the first Tim Burton movie
unfortunately it became you know not
just a ratings hit but a critical hit I
mean we got we got a rave review and
Entertainment Weekly who don't normally
review cartoons but it was kind of kind
of beyond even what we were expecting I
didn't have a clue
it was the first time I made a show and
for the first one the first roll talk
about talk about getting the brass ring
yeah but we had been recording these
things for months you know and Mark
Hamill and I remember we're both in the
set and the ADR room together at Warner
Brothers the first day to do ADR and on
this full screen that comes up the lush
color the rich graphics the the full
symphony score I just push off the
screen and I looked at mark I said did
you have a clue that this is what we've
been working on
he was just we both were just speechless
it was it was overwhelming that's when I
realized this was gonna be a hot show as
part of the 75th anniversary year when
her brothers animation has created a
couple of quick shorts and Bruce the
first one you worked on bad it just
debuted on the DC nation block and we
maybe you can give it a quick set up and
we want to show it for the people here
so they can see it on the big screen
well it's very short is you live you
sound like you've already seen it but
it's two minutes long and it's basically
an itch that I've had for years and I
finally got to scratch it I always kind
of wanted to do a straight-up period
piece version of Batman was set right
strike strictly in 1939 the year he was
created when I came up with that idea
that well then if I'm doing 1939 then
it's got to be in black and white so my
buddy here Peter Girardi was in charge
of the DC Nation shorts so I hit him up
with the idea and he said that's great
do it it's not my money it's more two
brothers mo yeah but I mean you know the
beat has what we call it internally from
the title sequence of beat as you can
tell wait a minute there's something
else going on here
there's the storytelling there's the
visuals as the way it's mixing together
there's the way it's forming something
that had never been done before
we had a chance to do these DC Nation
shorts and Bruce had this idea I mean I
wasn't going to say no so so you didn't
say no and this is the result video
Meister's do your magic yo you don't
scare me
[Music]
[Music]
is it is it over
for now
[Music]
all right we're going to stay in the
animation world and jump ahead to 1999
Batman Beyond appears in another
iteration that I think justified
everybody and and challenged everybody's
conceptions and I'm curious Bruce weird
that do you remember how where this idea
came from I could tell you exactly we
were meeting with Jamie Kellner who was
the president of the Warner Brothers
Network at the time we had just started
doing the what we call the revamp Batman
episodes it was the the new adventures
of Batman and he was like very
complimentary on the news show he really
liked it a lot he said but you know we
kind of want to do something a little
different with Batman and I'm uh huh
and he said yeah I'm thinking teenage
Batman I just kind of went holy crap
really and I think also the time I think
Buffy was like the The WB's huge huge
breakout hit at the time so I think he
was trying to like Buffy eyes Batman so
at first it was just kind of like Yanis
I don't even want to do this this is
going to be horrible but then I was out
in the parking lot talking with Paul
Dini after the meeting and I I said yeah
you know it's just I don't know this is
seem so commercial and so so not what we
do and then I said but you know if Bruce
Wayne got really really old and he
couldn't be Batman anymore so this takes
place in the future and then he has to
bring in like this this kid to be the
new Batman the old warrior passing the
torch onto the the new guy and you know
teaching them all his tricks I thought
yeah you know that might be something
and then the more we started talking
about it it's just kind of you know grew
and then I mentioned it to Glen Murakami
it was one of my co producers on Batman
and I mentioned him to the I mentioned
the idea to him in a minute I said
futuristic Batman he said that sounds
great let's do it and so at that point
it was kind of okay yeah I guess this
maybe maybe it won't suck so does that
mean Kevin that you get the call going
can you do an old Bruce Wayne voice you
have to practice an old voice they
wanted me to do a really old Bruce Wayne
so I had to get him really proud
so again as part of Batman 75 we have
another clip in Peter maybe you can talk
about this one for a moment yeah I mean
and once we decided to do the calling of
the earliest animated kind of version of
Batman that we had done with Bruce of
course the next thing that person I
talked about was what we should do a new
Batman Beyond short to go with the early
first strange days Batman so we called
Darwin cook Bruce did Bruce and Darwin
got back to use like getting the old
band back together and they came up with
a great take and I think you're going to
see it now
[Applause]
sorry pal but you're history who sent
that thing it didn't say whoever it was
they didn't stop at one
seven against two pretty bad odds for
them Batman Beyond fighting beat as
Batman here we are in 2002 and DC Comics
publishes Batman hush by Jeph Loeb drawn
by Jim Lee did you understand what was
going on when you and Jeff we're
creating this did you have any idea how
transformative this was going to be no
not really I mean we just you know I've
been at DC for three years already and
really hadn't done any monthly work and
I felt it was time to do something and
we knew that that would be concerned
with a schedule so I ended up doing a
lot of these issues in secret I think
only three people at DC knew that was
actually even working on this book you
know Jeff called me up and said look
we're gonna do it we should do a Batman
story that's the character that is most
popular DC that's how you'll make your
mark and he said like what character do
what villain do you want to use and I
remember saying uh well I kind of liked
all of them thinking he was just going
to pick one movie just like Batman vs.
the Joker whoever and maybe he
misunderstood me maybe he's just
sadistic but he basically crafted a
story was at new villain every single
issue you know it's interesting from
that last video we saw which
incorporated all the different elements
of Batman we wanted to really do a story
that actually did tie into a lot of
stuff that that you had seen before in
different decades of Batman mythology so
to that point he kind of starts out
looking like Frank Miller's Batman with
a shorter years and then with each
successive issue he kind of transforms
more into a life they're more acrobatic
Neal Adams Batman and then I there's
like a shot with all the Batmobiles I
think at the time we didn't have the
rights to do the 66 Batmobile but I put
it in there anyway
so if you see it there's like the
mortars I think are missing and some
like little tweaks just to kind of fudge
it a little bit but that was I mean I
had good reference I knew what I was
doing so don't blame me I think that
book really introduced me to the
fanaticism of Batman fans when you get
into comics as a professional you see
the the loyalty and the passion of the
fans but then when you do a Batman
project it goes to a whole different
secret like uber level it really opened
my eyes to the power of this mythology
of this character and it's it's a
character that you know I really loved
working on and look forward to doing
more of to meet another watershed year
comes in 2005 when you and Frank Miller
began working on all-star Batman and
Robin coming out in an oversized
absolute edition this summer right and I
would call this a fairly tumultuous
production yeah when I came out it was
actually a lot of people didn't like it
on the Internet they were that's not my
Batman and and I would say at least two
different people at DC almost got fired
over this book there was an issue which
had blacked-out bars I don't know if you
guys are familiar there was like a lot
of salty language in the black bars but
the printer made a error and you could
actually see the the words underneath
the black bars for some reason they
decided that it was important to have
the real words underneath the black bar
instead of just putting a black bar and
so those are collectors issues I saw one
about every week on eBay so if you look
for the auction you can find it but uh
yeah so but what's funny and I think
it's real proof and testament to the
power of Batman is that as crazy as that
story line was and the quote on the
goddamn Batman is now part of the
vernacular is now part of the mythology
and really shows you for as human as the
character is he is bulletproof in all
these different ways that you can tell a
crazy story where he's zebra Batman he
goes to the moon in the 50s and you
could do a story where he's very dark in
the Arkham games and in the Dark Knight
movie and and it still works
and he's multi-generational and appeals
to little kids and older fans and it's
it just goes to show you that all this
stuff basically goes into a giant
creative pool and you guys as the fans
decide what's important what works and
you are in that way
a shaping who Batman becomes but also
that year Christopher Nolan launched his
global phenomenon that is the Batman
trilogy I think these are the apotheosis
of superhero movies I think these movies
are actual art made from a story about a
guy wearing a mask and I'm just curious
for everyone on the group or whoever
wants to answer it where do you think it
goes next where do you where do you
think that the Batman storytelling goes
the technology has definitely caught up
with the mythology you can now have a
car or you can have a phone in your car
as was portended in the Batman 66 car TV
show so I don't know to me I think
there's going to be a broadening of the
Batman family you're in see more
diversification of that and I think the
technology is going to basically make
all his toys even cooler as before in
time but it's also the humanity of the
character I think that's made him so
resonant for so long you know he's he's
mortal he doesn't have any superpowers
and he's got such an incredible moral
compass he always does the right thing
that's what's made him last so many
years well you know one thing that's
interesting is that I think all the
stuff is cyclic Alif you go back you
know Batman start off really dark then
he got really silly with Adam West then
he got gradually darker and darker
through the Neal Adams years and through
the Frank Miller and then the Tim Burton
thing in my show and then it kind of it
kind of comes and flows I was meeting
with our boss Sam register and he said
he is what do you think we should do
next with Batman just just picking my
brain and I said well I think we've kind
of done like this dark serious Batman
for like you know 10 15 years now I
think we need to go back the opposite
way and embrace the the child like you
know aspects of a character that people
like when they were really little so
that's how they ended up doing you know
Batman Brave and the bold which I think
is just as valid a show in its own weird
way as any of the stuff we do so I'm be
really curious to see what they're gonna
do with the movies now I mean it's like
I'm actually really looking forward to
seeing Ben Affleck play Batman because I
think it's going to be a completely
different take on the character
and as we found is when you team him up
with Superman it's a whole different
world it's like it's not suddenly the
world that's like all bound by you know
supposed you know hard science and
physics it's like you know that's you
open up the door you know it's the
willy-nilly box you can end up you know
going to the moon if you want so so we
end here in the present day and we have
the current iteration of Batman this is
the number one monthly comic book in
America it has been since it launched
almost three years ago every collected
edition becomes a number one New York
Times bestseller in hardcover and in
paperback
he's never probably ever been stronger
critically and commercially in comic
form coming this fall we will be putting
out a book and math set based on the
third volume in their trilogy it's an
actual Joker mask mirroring his shaved
off face that you can put on and wear
and do god knows what with when you do
that so you have that and then the
newest world that Batman has conquered
massively popular series of Arkham
Asylum games the third version of which
is due shortly and perhaps the best
place to end this is the last most
recent iteration we have seen of Batman
[Applause]
Thank You Adam Phillips on the back of
the room my panelists I thank you so
much for probably one of the best hours
I've ever spent working at DC
entertainment I would love to do it
again thanks all of you for coming today
thank you so much
it's Batman Stephanie good anniversary
so we are gonna be celebrating all year
long because that's what you do for an
anniversary right well we've got
exclusive news insider tidbits and
updates for you all year long yeah so
you guys should subscribe right now cuz
you don't want to miss that right now
true
[Music]